so I really want to start with the
sincere this movie is awesome fastest
two hour and 30 minute movie I've seen
in a long time one of the things I don't
think people might realize is the unique
way that Tom and McHugh work and how
they'll reshoot things multiple times so
talk a little bit about that aspect as
an actor like the train sequence I guess
they kept filming it to just get it
better and figure out what they wanted
so as actors talk a little bit about
that that the way they work and what
it's like for you as actors I mean first
of all I think they also cast the actors
and then they
around the ACT
the activities and around what the actor
inspires them and around like ongoing
conversations that we have together you
know and also doing screen tests uh to
see like which hair which makeup which
outfit is going to go better with the
character and how how the person moves
and all these things so it's like it it
takes a lot of time to create the
character but it gives a lot of freedom
to the actor as well to do to do that
what would you like to add yeah I
suppose it's I remember saying to them
um we we did 40 takes of picking up a
key and it was it was so fun because
actually you realize both take 30.
you're thinking as an actor yeah you're
just picking up a key but I thought how
many ways can a human being pick up a
key yes and you get to play them all and
that's just one tiny example but in many
moments you get to play many many
different things because you get the
opportunity because there's time space
and it's the process of let's see what
comes out and then we have loads of time
in the edit and put putting things
together that are unusual and allows for
rather than being you know we're so used
to having one or two takes sometimes in
films when it's a small budget no but
also uh Krista from Macquarie has such a
sense of the frame and he's surrounded
by such an incredible crew and the
lighting is beautiful and the the set
and then we just play around and and
just really take the time to make
everything perfect you know so it feels
very special to get the opportunity to
do that one of the things that when
Chris and Eric are writing the
screenplay five years ago they could not
have known how much AI was going to be
what everyone is talking about right now
so uh talk a little about that aspect
because it does seem a little bit like
they're Nostradamus like they've nailed
it in terms of coming out at the right
time yeah well I we were saying it's
kind of it must have been somewhere in
the collective unconscious that there's
a feeling of this idea of how we
interact with technology and what it
means and how how much it is at utterly
now part of the system in our lives I
suppose and so it seems you know
unbelievably timely but also must be in
the kind of I don't know what Humanity
you're feeling right now and were a few
years ago but I think he was saying that
he thought about it in the back in 2019
right
crazy to think about that also something
else that don't people may not realize
about this movie is you've been filming
for 20 years
it's like the longest thing also the
longest shoot ever
um so talk a little about that aspect
because obviously when you signed on or
you couldn't have known you're going to
be filming this forever I mean I was
crazy I was never able to go back home
for longer than a year so that was a
little bit insane but I was so focused
on on the training and on the role and
on you know working with Tom and McHugh
I I learned so much you know oh I'm sure
what was it like for you well we started
I I finished this movie pieces of a
woman in the beginning of January 2020.
the others have started training 2019 I
couldn't because I was off doing that
movie landed back everyone flew to
Venice we were just about to shoot and
then covert happened literally that the
day before shooting so then it was
suspended obviously we had no idea it
was going to go back and then
unbelievably it did in 2020. so that's
three years really up to now yeah yeah
and then we we went to Norway in um uh
in September I think
September 2020. before I run out of time
I definitely want to ask an individual
question of each of you uh the car chase
sequence in Rome is like
I wanted to curse but I'm just going to
say it's F and incredible talk a little
bit about filming that sequence and what
it was like for you and also the train
sequence for you without getting into
any spoilers is a great sequence for
your character so what was it like
reading that on the page or reshooting
it 17 times to get what we see on the
screen I mean it's you know it was very
challenging changing you know like to to
shoot these these scenes but it's what
is beautiful it's that we shoot on in
real locations so we we get to to get to
to go to these beautiful cities and with
historical monuments you know so yeah
that was insane but also on the train
um yeah I remember like having to do a
fight scene in a such a tight place so
you have to kick super high but super
sharp and you have to be very precise
with everything you know so and you the
train too it's a it's a big big moment
for your character as well well I think
the train because it was an interior and
it was in a studio we could come back to
it so many times which is also amazing
because I think we shot that as one of
the very first scenes we shot
dialogue scenes and obviously at that
point everything's still going with the
flow and everything's changing so much
so when the the idea of the entity and
the key was being formed and exactly
what it did I think we came we shot many
times as I'm sure you've been told
um so it was a case of oh my God we're
back on this train again and uh yeah
then I had to come back sometimes
without Henry because he wasn't in the
country and him him without me and
um yeah but it's it's Mission so you
just get to play with many different
things and you get to go oh actually I
think I can do that better but just in
six months time so yeah and that no need
to go I'm just going to say sincerely
congrats movie is incredible uh good
luck with the rest of your speed dating
thank you thank you